you guys want to go to a new place yeah
I guess that always turns out good for
us that doesn't make any sense B oh no
no I was trying to close door behind you
Bob did you trap Bob in there yes yes it
did uh bald eagle is right behind you
and nope nope nope hello we're just
taking a we're just taking a break you
can if you want yeah go oh
okay okay no y I think Bob thinks we set
him up again like I didn't set him up
last time either but like it feels like
a set up I got to go bathroom I have a
resolution for this next move I am not
going to die first Mark's going to die
first okay help me make sure that Mark
dies before I do the Titan uh it's
storming so careful with your medals
group up group up for
safety fkk it's happening
FK oh my God oh God you got to get out
of here you got to get out of there hold
on one
[Music]
second okay go and get it get get to the
ship I'm just telling you you got to get
to the ship man
uh yeah just just get to the ship
there's a lot of lightning there's a lot
of problems and it's I I don't like any
of
[Music]
it what yeah I I think the only way I
haven't explored yet has a land mine
blocking it
nope
NOP
no
no wait he you don't have to run up to
me when your head's about to explode I
want to be alone Bob what happened to
you
apparently a tube of toothpaste is
enough metal to attract lightning from
the
sky ahz I was and literally I was
holding it and it was like buzz and I
was like whoop and I dropped it and I
didn't get one step away from it before
I got exploded by lightning God oh God
okay very dead yeah uh your flashlight
still on too I need to recharge that
what's up you're right so wait was there
a ghost out there or something
oh yeah oh it's actually just an emote
to explode your own head ah fun wait
this says stormy on here but it says
foggy on
here what oh we'll find out what the
truth is all right oh nice oh that's
cool that's great all right back to
Titan
eh yeah so do you like Titan or
something well I had to pay $700 for us
to come here so we kind of want to get
our money's worth oh you don't have to
pay in here you don't have to pay each
time wait it's echoey it's echoey to me
is that bad yeah it's a little
echoey uh I mean it's probably not good
is it better up here glad we yeah a
little bit uh no it's still you still
just kind of have voice for me yeah it's
a little echoey huh oh by the way fire
exit's right here
okay
I don't like this hey Mark do you know
where the fire is hey there's a turret
what oh okay this is a weird room did
you not encounter the turret no I didn't
where is it it's literally there's a
turret straight through the main exit
down that hallway down this hallway yeah
down this
one that one oh you
right got the
Sheep okay I'm stuck all right here we
go
whoa Pro moves there's nothing up
here clouded up there's a leaking valve
I went to turn it off and there's a
turret guarding the valve so fire X it
might just be a noo here I'll I'm going
yeah I'll go back to the ship and I'll
I'll turn some stuff off of you yeah
that sounds good already on my I'm
already
here oh
hello hey man all right Bob I'm coming
back in Good
Luck yeah there is a turret oh it's
spinning I can't disable it so I'm
assuming it can't see you hey wait can
you give me a look Lo and tell me what's
around me oh yeah you're going have to
give me one second though bomb's in a
bit of a rough
spot oh God I might be in a bit of a
rough spot wait I'm hearing some strange
stuff over here you're good what you
need Mark Mark we're going to try
something it may not go well um if you
crouch down and you go into the room to
your right here in a second you can try
to find the valve and disable the smoke
okay okay disabled I'm going to keep
disabling all
right oh my God oh my God where's the
freaking valve I can't see where the
valve
is
a oo oh oh my
God I hear it I don't see
[Music]
it oh my God oh my
God oh
oh well he died because the turret was
on a cool down I didn't think he could
shoot during the cool down did you know
that the turret can shoot during the
cool down I didn't know that hey you
know what I died last time but this time
I achieved my goal you did you literally
did want Mark to die specifically before
you and I don't know how that ended up
happening but grat I know you helped me
make it happen I know the truth I didn't
cry uh-huh yeah oh cuz Mark's listening
right right it was an accident mark it
was an accident you know where to send
the money
mhm uh yeah dis SK get
away man there was a lot of place oh hey
hey hey hey what's up guys hey I don't
know how the turret got you the moment I
was able to disable I disabled it every
time but the last time it was just
committed it didn't care it's funny cuz
I was dodging it for a very long
time it's broken up that you died Mark
like I was dodging it for a long
time I was disabling it I just kept
re-enabling I'm telling you I I did I
tried to help I did uhhuh for a long
Time come on don't be like that like a
long time I was bobing and
weaving we're going to have a great time
were you dodging I was dodging well I'm
going to need a flashlight so you better
Fork over the
cash what it's us the company boys we
got this
uhhuh a shovel the defend us to Great
uhhuh you know I could go in no
flashlight I guess yeah that's fine I
don't have a flashlight who needs a
flashlight all right no flashlights then
I bet you do have a flashlight and
you're trying to oh I've got an
assignment I must hunt and kill the
hoarding bug I must hunt and kill the
hoarding
bug I must hunt and kill the hoarding
bug I will hunt and kill the hoarding
bug I will kill
[Music]
the yes hey Mark you seen any
bugs oh
waing
bug come out come out hey if I find the
bug buddy for the first okay shovel here
in case we need to defend ourselves
later I'm going to blast a
boo it's dark in
here oh you could brought a flashlight
with me I had a sneaking suspicion that
you had a
flashlight I don't have a
flashl I've got an anvil there you
go am I going to be able to make this
jump with this Anvil oh yeah yeah I can
those thighs are
so he Bob was saying something dumb and
I didn't listen to it and cut him right
off I bet he feels
dumb is the jump the only way to go
still I think
so well I guess I could try the fire
exit H there's a soldier in here that's
interesting oh hi hey that's a lock door
unless we grab a key we can't go that
way oh I had oh I had a key did I drop
it over there there might be a key on
the
ground or no I saw a key in the other
room oh wait I know where a key
is I know where a key
is
oh B you good h a
oh I don't know if that's fine out
what I don't know what that
meant I don't know what that meant I
don't know what that meant I don't know
what that
meant
[Music]
uh how's everyone
doing oh oh oh it's a hoarding
bug I did it I did it
I did it I killed the hoing bug I I
killed the hoarding
[Music]
bug
hello good job bud should I come
back
no all right I'm coming
back oh I was
actually pull out here
oh my oh my God there's 100% out here oh
my God what in the hell was that about
that was the same thing that killed me
that was so
fast
yeah yeah Bob and I encountered a
nutcracker and we were trying to deal
with it and then I got killed from
behind by the same thing got you oh he
still thinks we're alive I think he
knows I'm
dead
did we lose weight at some point oh
never mind he does not
know oh that's not
good I mean if he makes a run for it I
don't see
dogs I think he'll be fine once it turns
yeah he should be good and now we should
go is anyone alive it's coming back oh
no oh no oh no oh oh God don't move Bob
don't move don't
move juste leave Mr
Tre uhoh no not that way oh he's fine oh
he's got nerves of Steel ooh that's
scary oh my
God hey man uh hey what's up hey how's
it going ah yeah so yeah I I died right
after we first were talking oh yeah the
thing that you found that funo skeleton
uh got me before it came to you yeah oh
I Wasing around to go hit the Nutcracker
yeah and then it came right for me
interesting yep oh we lost
everything yeah yeah it's fine we're
fine and it's company
day oh that's unfortunate you know you
see waade I keep reiterating this is you
pick the really dangerous places right
away before we have like a teleporter L
doy we always do good right after bat
and then you keep having this idea and
it's it's never worked it's never once
worked he right on that one it's never
once worked come on guys it's me it's
your pal it's it's actually never
worked I I don't I feel like it's just
ignoring her all right toally valid
criticism yeah we should do we should we
should go to
Titan how about no you know what would
be cool is if we had
money that we didn't spend it all on
going to Titan yeah okay you know that'd
be that'd be interesting to me you know
that a fair criticism cuz what I'm
seeing is like there's things like uh
you know a stun grenade a zap gun a
jetpack a radar booster P teleporters
night vision goggles medkits whatever a
peeper is a rocket launcher see there's
a lot of stuff here that can maybe help
our ability to survive and you've been
playing so long with other people that
have like no patience that you have
exacerbated your inability to wait
around and build up a good base of stuff
so that we can
endure plus then dying is way more
tragic cuz like I don't really feel like
we lost anything just now
guys look look at up look we are strong
we can do this we don't need to build up
and
get I I would love to see I've never
even used a jetpack cuz I always play
with you all we will try the build up
method you know what's funny is actually
we wouldn't have even needed that much
to get a jet pack we could have afforded
to Jetpack after the first one it's just
that someone if we 700 credits on Titan
is that what yeah yeah but but in fact
the jetpack costs exactly 700 credits oh
interesting bad roles we Tred a new
experence not a profit quarter your
performance has been deemed below stand
I feel like this is undercutting the
legitimacy of the criticisms that Mark
and I are raising right now
no ah new day new us no reason to ever
talk about the past cuz with a new
beginning hi yeah I'm new to this I
definitely uh am excited but also you
know I don't want to uh put it out there
but I I'm I'm still
new oh oh is uh place called Titan say
maybe we shouldn't let this one run the
computer oh no it's fine we're going to
Minecraft world remember how good
Minecraft world was to us it I feel like
Minecraft world breaks the
immersion I feel like we did that also
you don't want to go there we can okay
seem a very silly free it was very free
and um I mean if you want to take a look
at the other moons they all have some
weather going on but you know you can
pick one of those you want or you pick
buddy all right I'll pick
Moon
moons
yeah off a great start this new guy uh
you sure what about what about Dy what
about Dy that's seven oh dime cost 600
to go to do we have that oh no how do
you know it cost 600 check it how about
experimentation that sounds good that's
a classic it c yeah it flooded what's
the deal uh it's foggy that's it that's
not bad nothing how do I how do I Moon's
go
experimentation aha confirm I figured it
out you guys laughing you think I'm dumb
yeah Bob was done a really funny joke it
had nothing to do with you
yeah I got this emote for us cuz it's
called best M oh are we on the
floor I think so it's really foggy way
to find ah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh hey
guys I hear bees that's okay wao wo W wo
whoo wao was a bird all right so I found
the bees they're over there here's a
wall and I really hope there's nothing
bad out here cuz we would never see it
mhm but it would never see us probably
oh you know yeah right there bud yeah I
was stuck oh a
door most beautiful door
oh oh oh oh wow here yeah wao I like
like the mood lighting I don't I'm going
to have a I can't feel my eyes yeah I
can't see nothing oh I got a
wall CED metal sheet over here wait wait
wait save that for me save that it might
be my objective I might have an
objective where are you I'm going to try
to find a way to go down so we can where
are
you hi I see that I don't know if that's
my sheet it says I need scrap retrieval
find The Hive marked assignment Target I
don't know what it means by
Hive oh man I really can't see nothing
this should help
what
huh
oh man that's nice thank you yeah no
problem oh there is one way to go and
it's jumpies all right I can do jumps
hey I don't is hey hey hey what's this's
what see
whoa what oh well what oh where are you
hey guy wait nice what's up wait there's
a mine but it's a RBA it's a RBA man
mine what you sure it's a mine I don't
know I don't know I don't know that was
kind of miny oh it's a room of mine yep
it's a room of mine oh it might have
just been a
Roomba might just
Roomba
huh hey you guys
okay
hello what is whoa that's so weird what
is what is that hey where' you guys
go
guys
hello oh my God it's on my head help
help help anybody help
help I got a critical
injury I'm dead how we went to the easy
FL this is just free money oh yeah this
is good what happened to
you I just fell off and my I'm just an
idiot nothing else nothing nothing more
nothing less I'm just stupid all right
well that's
fair how long do you going to look for
us before it out I don't know I don't
know how we got so separated
either well I accidentally hit the
teleporter when I was panicking with the
with the little robotic mind there was a
teleporter yeah that's what that when
Wade stepped on that thing and
disappeared it teleported him oh it
wasn't a landmine no no it was
teleporter oh oh so there was a landmine
and there was a
teleporter
huh well I left some goodies outside so
hopefully you can get
something he's so
confused
oh God okay well you know these things
happen well if we just tell him to leave
early well he'll figure it
out yeah yeah we might as well he's
going back I want him to go back into
the
thing oh the
bees uh-oh
uhoh oh he's not worried he knows how to
handle bees
apparently oh good well he's
[Music]
fine oh were you crying were you crying
yeah I was cutting some onions to make a
dinner oh man that's hilarious anyway
that went well to you all huh I got a
gold bar but what what happened to you
guys oh man you should have seen it a
bug landed on my head and then I was
screaming and screaming and screaming
and screaming and screaming and
screaming then I died you know how that
room we were in when we were talking has
a little thing in the middle oh the hole
Yeah yeah that oh cuz yeah we were
talking and I was like yeah Bob and then
I came in and didn't hear anything and
then like in the distance I
hear I actually turned into a face
hugger and killed Mark oh but then yeah
Mark did you want to pick our moon again
you seem to be the expert on moon so
yeah yeah yeah uh I like this place I
like this place okay I me we can stay
here I like this place all right F let's
do this
oh it wants me to kill a bunker spider I
don't know how I'm going to do that
Austin what weapon I don't know we'll
find out swing your huge dick I
will
oh HH you turned into a
robot I don't like
robots not very right I just don't like
him
oh that's dir oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God I didn't know that was a
thing that's Could Happen what is that
mean oh why is it so dark in that area
but that's fine hello
hey man
Mark where you at oh
helloy hi uh if you go if you if you go
down way and just be careful like
through this door to the right don't go
down there there's a turret at the far
end I almost got got but I was too good
for it
um yeah just be
careful
oh my God what was
that do you hear something
running uh oh oh there's a spider I see
a spider oh
god oh oh that's another hi oh God oh
God down there uh I don't know oh oh I
don't know man it's
bad oh okay
it's so dark I can't see
anything that was a
squeak use your scaners sow Bob I'm
trying
to oh my God it's a hoarding bug give me
that give me that give me that what are
you doing give me that all right hey
give me that what are you doing with
that yeah you better give me that aha
it's mine
now it's mine now it's mine now now it's
mine
now I think you just di the
table oh man I I thought I would
show God damn it engine I had man we're
uh I did have an engine
right must have grabbed it I was getting
that engine back for you bud that was a
it's trying you think he's going to
check no he's not going to check yeah we
should vote let's vote let's vote to
leave early so he doesn't well I guess
he wants to get his stuff he probably
has more stuff at the door I put mine in
let him let him grab the next wave of
stuff and then yeah you're
right it's mine
now it's mine
now oh no he's going back in you guys
good yeah we're fine yeah yeah yeah it's
F turns out out walking around without a
flashlight
oh oh no yeah they got pissed oh my God
oh my God
okay did they both die to a loot bug
yeah let's just say we did no let's say
yeah loot bug that's what got it yeah no
you know what that is better you're
right you're right you're right y y yep
yep I hear you I I heard was mine
[Laughter]
now man we are really inching past
these it's good it's good it's
good I have not played this game like a
ton but this is the least successful
I've been
ever I by such a wide margin a loot bug
yeah a loot bug let's just go with loot
bug man let's go with loot bug oh man
those loot bugs the man yeah they're
very dangerous yeah they're so dangerous
and that's why we died yep
yeah happen yep did you guys fail a jump
No Loot bug didn't I did not jump okay I
didn't I can't hear anything hold on
headphones hello wait all right anyway
loot bugs are they they are problematic
going
back okay
yipp I was just telling way that
definitely the loot bug and it was the
bear the bear the bear the bear the bear
oh the
bear the bear
what you mean Freddy Fazbear question
mark oh the Bear's fine oh the bear I
see yes oh that's fine that's fine ah
yield sign I'm going to go get a yield
sign yeah this time we're all good
everyone No Loot bugs are going to get
on our way sounds
good
idiot
hey called us ID Mark he did well he
called you an idiot
Steam
ah my
eyes not dead yet not dead
yet not dead yet not
dead that's a land mine not dead not
dead hey friend yeah what's up not dead
who's an idiot now not dead not dead he
a fire exit go anywhere key all right
not dead not
dead it's
great not dead
hey Not
Dead uh I need a key here too
great not
dead
nice needs a key yeah what's
up not dead
I am not
dead not
dead oh dead
end want come to this loot Zone uh loot
Zone where where'd you go where where
did you go where' you go the teleporter
where did you go here where' you go hey
hey what's up not dead Tor where does
this go oh
oh no I heard that oh cool oh hey what's
up how it going okay watch your
St heard there with the teleporter kind
of just got to guess where it is hey
Mark
Mark Mark oh wait I'm going to fall in a
hole I don't like this room I wouldn't
do that Mark it's it's too dark
dark how did he see that how did he how
did he see
that oh my God he's
cheating hello oh my God he's
[Music]
cheating